-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Guys, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Father's Day is this Sunday.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Congress just held another
hearing about January 6th.
The first photo
of Ryan Gosling as Ken...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...in the "Barbie" movie is out.
And I just heard Jack Daniels
is teaming up with Coca-Cola
to sell a canned Jack & Coke.
[ Cheering and applause ]
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
Here we go.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
First up, this Sunday
is Father's Day.
It is the time to thank your dad
for everything
he's done for you.
It's a fun day to celebrate,
but you know what's not so fun?
The congressional hearings.
[ Laughter ]
They're investigating
January 6th.
That's when a mob went
after Mike Pence,
who, by the way, has as much
going on below the belt as
A Ken doll.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What can you do, you know?
He's a Ken doll.
I mean,
and Ken and Barbie,
they're a great couple.
I mean, they go together like
Jack & Coke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, you can get it
as a premixed cocktail,
which is good news
if you still need a gift for
Father's Day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Your dad deserves
something special.
Because it's not easy
raising kids.
I mean, before he had you,
your dad probably looked like
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ryan Gosling. I mean,
just look at him.
If that Ken walked
into a bachelorette party,
there'd be a full-on
Riot.
[ Laughter ]
People stormed the Capitol,
and took selfies
while they did it.
You know, they must've pregamed
with a few
canned cocktails.
[ Laughter ]
If you drink one, you drink six.
I mean, they go down
real smooth.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of down and smooth...
Poor Ken.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He'll never be able to be a
Dad. So...
[ Laughter ]
...in conclusion --
Nice abs.
Tastes bad.
Make it stop.
[ Laughter ]
Love you, Pop.
[ Cheering and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪